I think I know about the wax Trax Channel
what's up
I downloaded it
all right
then I guess you just oh my God that's so
cool
fantastic hey welcome to Discord to the
stage
again this is sources a good notification we
are on at which we are live on Twitch we are
going to be installing and testing Docker
desktop sorry ranch or desktop which is a
replacement Shoe Doctor desktop
and I've already got it on on my laptop for
work and want to try it there than most
because I have conflicts with anyconnect on
your cell so I think this might actually get
around it
and when are you writing an installer for
Linux which I don't know that I would
actually use you know it's pretty damn easy
to
to said you know just had a doctor said like
that on Linux but I'm not going to sit at
his right now I'm actually running quite a
bit of other stuff right now
I still have all my other mini Cube stuff
running
yeah I've got I've got a ton of a ton of
jobs running from my previous thing we are
going to switch back to that by the way
later we will definitely switch back to that
I'm going to I got to figure out how to
drain
got to figure out how to drain nodes and and
stuff and I ended up moving it First Take a
side track down this thing
80's and 90's industrial sounds great
ouch all right so first things first
I get a thing download is pretty fucking big
so I'm going to go ahead and do that
and I probably I probably take down this
this this this this this thing here make you
I can go ahead and just destroy listening
but Danny Keough destroy
where's the delete delete Dash p i knowed
off
lap so that's just I'm turning down if I
don't do this it's going to
and I'm going to come and blow up my system
should be a lot happier now
if I'm a suspect the chill up I love the 80s
music but this kind of thing will put some
80's on the on the on the on the brakes
so
what are communities yeah I can give him a
super brief explanation of that I've done
that in my in my boots videos as well
Similac checks to wax Trax channel here
absolutely yeah if you give me a link
Porsche
I love to eat it okay so just I'm going to
spend five minutes on this
and we'll talk about so actually consume in
a little bit
hello you don't need to do it is it is
I want to phone them
white rice Wednesday
I can't I can't stream another streamers but
oh my God this is so cool how do I
I not know about this
oh my God this is so honored.
Oh my God oh my God really that on yeah
hey I don't know where the music's coming
from its Justice website I was on
no one needs to say anything about that oh
my God it's great to have
Alexander youtubing stuff to which is
whatever I've been checking track to his off
the way to do the safe way to turn track two
off
I'm going to check out I can understand his
all right
search mean alright so and
as soon as the simplest way I can say it is
do you know what virtual machines are he
normally does explanation includes
explaining what a virtual machine is
it because you have to understand a virtual
machine is really before you can understand
what a what a container is okay so
containers give you effectively the same
thing as virtual machines for a fraction of
the performance cost because instead of
having multiple simulated hosts machines you
have everything uses the underlying host
operating system but in every other way is
separate and distinct so you can have any
uses it's been an able to buy something
called I think it's a fella facts which is
is you know it's in the old days if you if
you know Linux containers are just an
extension of Schrute
which means you know you can go into a point
in your system and you can shoot into that
and then nobody can break out you can't get
out of it it's safe it's wet. Here's the
thing it shares memory and it sure has a new
line just volumes I tried everything but it
has a different LXE thank you it but it has
a a different schruted Mountain point at the
users are the same and everything so you get
what looks like effectively there's me here
I'm going to run back to run at 500 because
everything has to use the exact same Colonel
that you're on Linux kernel so and it that
and it only works unless you cannot have
a container
that is a different type of architecture
like my chip architecture like you can't
have so for example we have run here I can
run it 12 I can run an entire a bunch of
insincere right or if I wanted to I could
run red hat
I think I don't think there was a redhead
image anybody run Alma
I'm at 8 I wonder if there's a helmet is
there a number eight you can run Kali Linux
you can run Arch Linux Arch
whichever I don't remember their name and
each one is an image and it uses a Target
also so why why use containers right well
containers let you
you know do one thing at the end of the day
I can't Aynor is a running image that's the
surrounded it's based on a single executable
at but that Grace of lions like when I run
you know when I run a bunch you like this
like what what's the image mr. Rob look at
the ears image in that case is a simulated
operating systems I call this a space
container but you know anything you do in
here gets thrown away that difference
between virtual machines and containers
containers are ephemeral why are they
important because you can run microservices
inside of them and and had a few days and
just stuff yeah
what you request from software engineers
what are your request from selfridges
so a software engineer would be asked to put
their application in a containerized way so
in order to run like I have is not running
right now but I have nginx set up so that it
will it will stream to YouTube and twitch
and I can run all of it including postgres
value proposition that containers give us
containers give us the ability to combine a
bunch of complicated applications a database
and one container you know a middleware and
another container back in service another
container and in front end servicing kit
with all those in containers that we can run
them all with one shot
all with one shot in fact we can put all
that stuff in a single container we can put
them on a collection of containers and in
the Technologies like talking impose allows
to run all of those at the same time and
bring him up all at the same time and take
him down very pretty much as soon as I can
be simple that guy singing monitoring system
which is in you know that the next version
Nadia's basically it has post grass and has
another database anona has Apache in there
and it had their all configured and
everything and then it's it's got a ton of
like architectural pieces that you would
have to install separately and they're all
put together in a single container actually
in that case multiple containers and then
those containers can be run with you know
they can be running with with one command
and then you can be torn down if we come in
and they don't do anything to your system
they just they just they just just do around
so when you when you start with that